usually I'm sort of provocative and
stuff but I actually find myself kind of
somewhat intermediate in this in this
argument and with a little bit of an
urge to push back in both directions
listening to Bob I have a little bit the
reaction you know planes crash and we
get the aviation industry and
investigate may explain how there was
this problem in the guidance system and
there's bit of pilot error in this bit
of this and you know okay well that
makes sense and you guys really are the
experts if a lot of planes crash and
they keep crashing at a certain point
you kind of want to step back and take a
look at the aviation industry and how
they're approaching it and what the
paradigm is and I I think we got I think
we're kind of at that point with respect
to financial engineering a bit above and
I think that's something that's one's
got to recognize on your side of the
argument on the other side of this I
think there is this slightly Luddite
tendency to suppose that this is all
associated with financial engineering
and modernity I mean let's just go back
Japan you know had a financial crisis
that cost them a decade plus 12 15 years
of performance of their economy they
didn't have any financial engineering
none they had traditional banking
working in traditional ways there are a
lot of things you can say about the tech
bubble but it was mostly people going to
their brokers and buying stocks that had
gone up and the stocks going up too much
and then the stocks falling and then
there being a big mess that wasn't about
financial engineering and it wasn't
about derivatives there was a
traditional financial institution seen
as a traditional make regular finances
work Fannie Mae and Freddie and Freddie
Mac when I was a graduate student bob
was talking about how if you think about
it right the government's got a put
option with respect to Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac because it's guaranteeing
all the liabilities and somebody ought
to be valuing that put option rather
than pretending it doesn't exist but
there was for a variety of reasons
financial and the engineers were kept
entirely away from that
exercise and so that put option was
allowed to grow with very serious
consequences for the ultimate economy so
I guess where I would hope people would
come down with a sense that financial
engineering wars too important to leave
to generals and financial engineering is
much too important to leave to finish
leave only to financial engineers and
that there are going to need to be some
important paradigmatic changes but at
the same time let's not forget that
there's sort of been greed and fear and
changing proportions of greed and fear
that have caused financial crises since
the ancient Greeks